We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1998, Dr. Gary Kaplan, the CEO of Virginia Mason Medical Center in Seattle, received some bad news about his hospital. It was losing money.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学促进所有生物生活质量的宗旨。请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗马·马尔斯。1998年，西雅图弗吉尼亚梅森医疗中心的首席执行官加里·卡普兰博士收到了一些关于他医院的坏消息。它在亏损。
That voice says David Weinberg, who's doing our reporting for us today. So back to the story. The STEM losses at Virginia Mason, Dr. Kaplan, start studying how other hospitals are managed. So we started scouring the country, looking for a hospital with a management system worth adopting.
大卫·温伯格说道，他是我们今天的记者。所以回到这个故事。弗吉尼亚梅森医疗中心的STEM亏损，卡普兰博士开始研究其他医院是如何管理的。于是我们开始在全国范围内搜寻，寻找一个值得借鉴的管理系统的医院。
And if you're anything like me, when you hear the phrase management system, part of your brain begins to shut down and another part of your brain prepares itself for hearing a lot of either complete nonsense or common sense, tarted up with unnecessary jargon. But really, all you need to understand here is that Dr. Kaplan was looking for a hospital
如果你和我差不多，当你听到“管理系统”这个词时，你大脑的一部分开始关闭，而另一部分大脑则准备好听取大量要么是完全废话，要么是用不必要的行话包装的常识。但实际上，你在这里需要了解的全部就是卡普兰博士在寻找一家医院
that had processes and procedures that were better than what he was already using, but he never found one. So instead, he ended up in Japan at a Toyota factory. Yep, the automobile company. And think about that. This is a very smart physician who goes around the country looking for a great management system and doesn't find one.
它拥有比他现有的更好且的流程和程序，但他从来没有找到这样的医院。所以最后，他去了日本的一家丰田工厂。没错，就是那家汽车公司。仔细想想。这是一位非常聪明的医生，他走遍全国寻找一个伟大的管理系统，却什么也没找到。
Charles Kenny is the author of Transforming Healthcare, a book about Virginia Mason's journey to adapt the Toyota production system to healthcare. He says that when Dr. Kaplan told his staff, they would be changing everything about the way they operate, and the changes were based on a car company, and that the doctors and nurses should refer to their new teachers as Sensei,
查尔斯·肯尼是《变革医疗保健》一书的作者，该书讲述了弗吉尼亚梅森将丰田生产方式应用于医疗保健的历程。他说，当卡普兰博士告诉他的员工，他们将改变运作方式的一切，这些改变是基于一家汽车公司，并且医生和护士应该称呼他们的新老师为“Sensei”（老师）时，
the response was not pretty. There was a lot of anger from people within his organization led by the doctors of course. And this whole multi-year overhaul started with a ball of blue yarn. The staff met with a sensei and he took out the ball of blue yarn and a map of the hospital and he told the staff to trace the path a cancer patient would take on a typical visit for chemotherapy treatment. And then the yarn went across a couple inches and then it maybe went up approximately five inches to where they'd have to get their blood drawn and then they would go up to the
大家的反应并不好。组织内部的人充满了愤怒，当然主要是由医生带头的。而这场历时多年的全面彻底改革，竟是从一团蓝色毛线开始的。员工们见了一位Sensei，他拿出一团蓝色毛线和一张医院地图，让员工们追踪癌症患者进行典型化疗访问时的路径。然后毛线穿过了几英寸，接着可能向上大约五英寸，到达他们抽血的地方，然后他们会去往
14th floor and on the cardboard that was like maybe four inches above that. Michelle Wetland is a nurse manager at Virginia Macy. And then they'd have to come and see their doctor, which was in a different location. And it was so big on our board that we just had to keep winding it around itself. And that's Dr. Henry Otero. Creating kind of this circular maze,
14楼，那块纸板大概比刚才高四英寸左右。米歇尔·韦特兰是弗吉尼亚梅森的护士长。然后他们必须去见他们的医生，医生在另一个地方。它在我们的板子上太大了，以至于我们不得不把它一圈圈绕起来。那是亨利·奥特罗博士。创造了一种环形的迷宫，
like we would wind a yo-yo. And when we looked at it, we were amazed at how far our patients traveled. We were asking oncology patients who are... their oxygen carrying capacity is compromised because the chemotherapy destroys a lot of red blood cells so that makes them short of breath. And here we're asking patients to do this who are short of breath to begin with. So it was appalling to us. And I think it was that mapping of the flows of medicine and the patient understanding, the patient's journey was that eye opening moment that you
就像我们绕着转盘一样。当我们看着它时，我们惊讶于我们的病人们走过了这么远的距离。我们在要求那些...由于化疗破坏了大量红细胞，携氧能力受到损害的肿瘤患者，这使他们呼吸急促。而这里我们却要求本来就呼吸急促的患者这样做。所以这让我们感到震惊。我认为，正是这种医学流向和患者理解的绘制，对患者旅程的理解，是一个让人大开眼界的时刻，你
realize you don't really know what's going on. The blue yarn told the story of what Virginia Mason was doing wrong. We just didn't, we couldn't conceive of it until actually until we saw it visually. And the story it told was not a good one to Dr. Otero. He thought he was providing exceptional care for his patients. They basically came into my exam room and they left. And I really said, I'm a great doctor. Look at this great care I give.
意识到你真的不知道发生了什么。蓝色毛线讲述了弗吉尼亚梅森做错的事。我们只是没有，直到亲眼看见它，我们才想象得到。它讲述的故事对奥特罗博士来说并不好。他以为他正在为他的病人们提供卓越的护理。他们基本上走进我的检查室，然后离开。我真的会说，我是一个伟大的医生。看看我提供的这些伟大的护理。
I see them, I send them out. And, you know, they just must feel like Look at this great care I gave. I see them, I send them out, and they just must feel like they have this great experience of having care here. Then he saw the twisting path of the blue yarn. Oh, how awful it is for them. How awful it must be to really wait everywhere along the way and that I was contributing to that and that,
我看到他们，我送他们走，而且，你知道，他们一定觉得——看看我提供的这些伟大的护理。我看到他们，我送他们走，而且他们一定觉得他们在这里接受护理的体验非常棒。然后他看到了蓝色毛线扭曲的路径。哦，这对他们来说是多么可怕啊。沿途到处等待一定有多么痛苦，而我正在助长这一点，并且，
it became an intolerance really too. I couldn't accept it anymore. Six months after that first meeting, Dr. Mecklenberg, the hospital's chief of medicine, led a group of staff on a three week trip to Japan to meet with a different sensei. And so they pulled out the schematic, essentially an architect drawing of various parts of the Virginia Mason Medical Center. And the Sensei kept pointing to these areas and saying, what is that?
这也变成了一种无法容忍的事。我再也无法接受了。那次会议六个月后，医院的医学主任梅克伦堡博士带领一组员工对日本进行了为期三周的访问，去见一位不同的Sensei。所以他们拿出了图纸，基本上是弗吉尼亚梅森医疗中心各个部分的建筑图。这位Sensei一直指着这些区域说，那是什么？
And Dr. Mecklenberg would say, well, that's a waiting area. And this happened over and over again. Well, that's a waiting area. And as this was happening, the Sensei seems to him to be getting increasingly angry. And he says to Mecklenberg, Why are there so many waiting areas throughout this facility? Who's waiting there? What are they doing? What are they waiting for?
梅克伦堡博士会说，哦，那是候诊区。这反反复复发生。哦，那是候诊区。随着这一幕的发生，这位Sensei看起来越来越生气。他对梅克伦堡说，为什么这个设施里有这么多的候诊区？谁在那里等？他们在做什么？他们在等什么？
And Dr Mecklenberg says, Those are our patients. They're waiting for us. And the Sensei long pause looks quite furious, looks directly at Dr. Mecklenberg and in front of Mecklenberg's team says to him, aren't you ashamed? And Dr. Mecklenberg said at that moment he was ashamed, he was absolutely ashamed. If I told you to picture a waiting room, you probably picturing a doctor's office. This is what we are trained to do when we go to the doctor. We are trained to wait. But to a sensei, who's been trained in the Toyota production system, waiting is a form of waste.
梅克伦堡博士说，那些是我们的病人。他们在等我们。Sensei长久地沉默着，看起来十分愤怒，直视着梅克伦堡，并在梅克伦堡的团队面前对他说，难道你不感到羞耻吗？梅克伦堡博士说，那一刻他感到羞耻，他绝对感到羞耻。如果你让我想象一个候诊室，你可能脑海中浮现的是医生的办公室。这就是我们去看医生时被训练去做的事。我们被训练去等待。但对一个在丰田生产方式中受过训练的Sensei来说，等待是一种浪费。
And the number one tenant of the TPS is to eliminate waste. The staff completely redesigned the Cancer Center, and they hired an architect who had first-hand knowledge of cancer treatment as a patient. He designed the journey differently to really be patient first. The new design put patients on the outer edges of the building, in these rooms with big windows that led in natural light and provided views of the pujits sound. But in order to give the patients these rooms, they had to take them away from the doctors who had their offices there.
而丰田生产方式（TPS）的第一大信条就是消除浪费。员工们完全重新设计了癌症中心，他们聘请了一位曾作为患者亲身经历过癌症治疗的建筑师。他以真正“患者第一”的理念重新设计了整个就医流程。新的设计将患者安排在建筑的最外围，在这些有巨大窗户的房间里，自然光可以照进来，并能看到普吉特海湾的景色。但为了给患者这些房间，他们不得不把这些房间从原本在那儿拥有办公室的医生那里拿走。
It wasn't something that really was difficult for me because I think we were always in the right direction with the patient. I think for others who maybe didn't go through that process, they saw it as a takeaway. I had the great office, the great window. Now you're putting me in this cubicle. I'm the guy who does all the work. It shouldn't I had the great office, the great window. Now you're putting me in this cubicle, you know, and I'm the guy who does all the work, you know, you know, it shouldn't I, it shouldn't I have the the big office. Some doctors were so angry they quit, but Dr. Otero says that everyone who stayed realizes it was the right thing to do for the patients. When I go there and I see them there and I see them looking out and I recognize that's a much better place than be. I'm gratified that decision was made and it's totally was the right decision. It's not even a question about it. Relocating patients was just the beginning.
这对我来说并不是一件真的很困难的事，因为我认为我们一直都在朝着对患者正确的方向前进。我想对于其他人，也许没有经历过这个过程的人，他们认为这是一种剥夺。我有很好的办公室，很好的窗户。现在你把我放进这个隔间里。我是那个干所有活的人。难道我不应该——我有很好的办公室，很好的窗户。现在你把我放进这个隔间里，你知道，我是那个干所有活的人，你知道，难道我不应该，难道我不应该有那个大办公室吗？有些医生气得辞职了，但奥特罗博士说，留下来的人都意识到这是对患者做出的正确决定。当我走到那里，看到他们坐在那里，看到他们向外眺望，我认识到那是一个比原来好得多的地方。我为做出这个决定感到欣慰，这绝对是正确的决定。这甚至不是一个问题。重新安置患者只是开始。
Today the New Cancer Center has been dubbed the Cancer Spa. It was designed to create an environment of healing so it has, it's a real pretty pale yellow color. We use colors of nature so yellow for sunshine and we have browns to simulate in greens to simulate nature and we have a water wall. There's two of them actually. And just so you don't think that this new management system resulted only in natural colored walls and big windows. The whole reason why this blue yarn was unspooled to begin with was to save the hospital money, and it did, and it also made it a safer place. From 2007 to 2009, Virginia Mason was so much safer that their insurance expenses declined
如今，新的癌症中心被称为癌症水疗中心。它的设计旨在营造一个疗愈的环境，所以它有一种非常漂亮的浅黄色。我们使用大自然的颜色，黄色代表阳光，我们有棕色来模拟，绿色来模拟大自然，我们还有一个水墙。实际上有两个。为了让你们不觉得这个新的管理系统只带来了自然颜色的墙壁和大玻璃窗。最初展开这团蓝色毛线的全部原因是为了给医院省钱，确实省了，而且它也变得更安全了。从2007年到2009年，弗吉尼亚梅森的安全度大大提高，其保险费用下降了
by an astonishing 37%. While simultaneously increasing the number of patients they treated, all without having to hire any additional staff. And yet some people still scoff at the idea of Toyota inspired management. I was on a boat once and someone said to me, so are you guys still building Toyota's in your basement? And that was a real, I mean I was offended because I knew that what we're doing here is really good.
惊人的37%。同时他们治疗的患者数量也有所增加，这一切都没有聘请任何额外的员工。然而，有些人仍然对受丰田启发的管理理念嗤之以鼻。我曾经在一艘船上，有人对我说，所以你们还在地下室造丰田车吗？那真是一个——我的意思是，我被冒犯了，因为我知道我们在这里做的事情真的很好。
And I said to him, you know, you can say what you want to make fun of what we're doing, but we're trying to do the best by the patient. This complete upheaval of the medical industry, which stemmed from a single thread of blue yarn, became especially poignant when the staff visited Japan for the first time, and saw an exhibit at the Toyota History Museum. It was an automatic loom. That was where the team learned that the Toyota production system was in fact born quite literally from a single thread of yarn.
我对他说，你知道，你可以说你想说的话来取笑我们做的事，但我们在尽力为患者做到最好。这场源于一根蓝色毛线的医疗行业大颠覆，在员工们首次访问日本并参观丰田产业技术纪念馆的一个展览时变得格外动人。那是一台自动织布机。也就是在那里，团队了解到丰田生产方式实际上真的是从一根毛线诞生的。
Might have even been blue. Toyota was originally a textile manufacturer and in 1902, Sakichi Toyota invented a self-correcting loom that would stop when a thread was broken or woven incorrectly. The museum is a story of continuous process improvement. You start with back breaking work on a manual loom that is producing defective product and you put in the first components of ergonomics, putting the person sitting up instead of sitting on the floor.
甚至可能是蓝色的。丰田最初是一家纺织制造商，1902年，丰田佐吉发明了一种自动织布机，当纱线断裂或织错时它就会停机。这个博物馆讲述的是持续流程改进的故事。你从在手工织布机上做着让人腰酸背痛的工作开始，产出的是有缺陷的产品，然后你引入了人体工程学的第一个组件，让人坐着工作而不是坐在地上。
Then you start making automatic looms and improve the machinery. Then you start developing mistake-proofing into the process that if any of the weave or the weft breaks, the machine stops and prove the machineries function as time goes on. Add speed and velocity. I see that at Virginia Mason, we're still just, we've just gotten off the floor sitting on the chair. We've got a couple of mistake-proofing things in the iron and some day we might be an automatic loom, but that might be 30, 40 years from now.
然后你开始制造自动织布机并改进机械。然后你开始在流程中开发防错机制，如果经纱或纬纱断裂，机器就会停下来，随着时间的推移不断改进机器的功能。增加速度和速率。我看到在弗吉尼亚梅森，我们仍然只是，我们才刚离开地面坐在椅子上。我们在一些环节中加入了防错机制，也许有一天我们会成为一台自动织布机，但这可能是30、40年后的事了。
But we've got a long way to go to mistake proof healthcare due to in a cost-efficient manner. 99% Invisible was produced this week by David Weinberg with help from me Roman Mars. It was made possible with support from lunar Making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW 91.7 local public radio in San Francisco, the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco in the Center for Architecture and Design. To find out more, go to the website, it's 99%Invisible.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但我们还有很长的路要走，才能以成本效益高的方式实现医疗保健的防错。本周的“99%隐形”由大卫·温伯格制作，并得到了我罗马·马尔斯的帮助。本节目的制作得到了 lunar 的支持，它用创意创造不同。这是旧金山本地公共广播电台 KALW 91.7、旧金山美国建筑师学会以及建筑与设计中心的一个项目。欲了解更多信息，请访问网站 99%Invisible.org。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。